a quiz on Drago magic on Robo that we
see this place is magical it's higher
than all the museums in a radius of
seven kilometers you can see all the
Vatican City from you with its gardens
and Hills st. Peters and the colonnades
and it towers above Rome the papal City
which is my hometown and that's why it's
my favorite spot
and Abby said so VD from Bob the
appointment of a woman like Barbara
gotta to head the museums with overdue
there's no reason at all not the
slightest why the Vatican Museums have
to be run by a man da Vatican is
moussine like a NASA dudenice amo molto
share a delay became proud of her
when a woman climbs that high in the
Vatican that's a reason to celebrate if
she can succeed
so can we do schita
this is a man
but it would be nothing
without a woman ha
Barbara otters appointment was a
sensation a year ago she was named
director of the Vatican Museums the
collections contain nearly a quarter of
a million treasures administered by a
host of historians curators and
conservators traditionally all men an
art historian and trained conservator
Yatta was four years in charge of the
prints and drawings section at the
Vatican Library at first she was one of
only three women Intimus Keely J mu say
it was a male-dominated world in the
secular museums I had worked in there
were more women on the other hand when I
left the Vatican Library 20 years later
about half the staff were female the
papacy adapted to social reality it was
inevitable mainly would that be like
another killer faction the first woman
to head the Vatican Museums still faces
enormous challenges six million visitors
pass through these hallowed halls each
year as many as 30,000 on a good day and
all of them want to see the Sistine
Chapel with its famous Michelangelo
frescoes
extended opening times haven't eased the
pressure now Barbara yata is trying to
reroute the stream of visitors Rho new
nico : ago canal a dozen there is only
one entrance to the Sistine Chapel
visitors have to pass through the map
galleries and the room of The Scindia
Torah we're working on an alternative so
that the chapel can be reached from
various sites because of security
considerations but is being supportive
also for that it Bob Reata believes in
modern style management her declared
goals are better cooperation between
departments digitization and targeted
conservation although she was surprised
by her appointment she's not blind to
its significance
Lamia na minha if it eva Maintenon
personal guard seems an important
message to the world at large that Pope
Francis wants to break down old patterns
there were six candidates at first then
three and I was the only woman maybe
that was what struck him and he decided
to appoint me you totally change them
the austrian-born journalist Goodwin
Siler has worked at Vatican Radio for
the past 15 years since Pope Francis
ordered a shake-up of the church's
communication structures the hierarchy
at the Vatican broadcaster has leveled
out there are more women working at the
Vatican than most people think of the
160 or so journalists employed by
Vatican Radio about half are women they
say they're respected by their male
colleagues and treated as equals when
you talk to certain bishops or Cardinals
they're well aware of the problems many
women in the Catholic Church are turning
away because they don't feel they're
taken seriously women want to be more
visible in different parts of the
worldwide church there's a growing
sensitivity to that desire and it's also
reaching the Vatican the unlegal phone
of knock knock mrs. Picard becoming more
visible as part of the challenge
hardly anybody sees what goes on behind
the walls of the Vatican but a quarter
of the staff are women many more lay
women the nuns and many of them highly
qualified
Romilda for outer was editor-in-chief of
the French section of Vatican Radio for
25 years looking back she remembers how
difficult it was at the beginning how
some Cardinals thought it beneath their
dignity to be interviewed by a woman and
simply ignored her
Oh Safed no quando Oh Shiva Nataraja yo
a feral intervie spelling pattern as
soon as I love the studios to interview
somebody at the Vatican it was dreadful
when I was in a larger group of men I
always had the feeling like that I was
somehow invisible when I asked a
question the Cardinals would reply to my
male colleagues not to me although I was
holding a microphone and had everything
they needed to recognize this mentality
of pushing women to the margins of the
workplace still exists everywhere women
are supposed to be mothers brides or
nuns they may work but they shouldn't
want a career unfortunately that's what
many women also think that it's wrong to
seek too much attention to ask for too
much yeah Madonna win most as a
Pollyanna
the Catholic Church teaches that
humility and modesty are virtues Pope
Francis himself is critical of
career-minded priests and he often
speaks out against traditional power
structures that may be why he wants to
see more women taking leadership roles
people like the director of the Vatican
Museums Barbara yatta the Catholic
journalist Christiana Florian welcomes
this development but she says it doesn't
go far enough she has recently written a
book demanding more power for women in
the Catholic Church why is it considered
inappropriate for women especially for
women to raise the question of power
when they raise this question which I
also do in my book they're always told
the church is not about power the church
is about service and humility but that's
not true it's also about positions of
power the person who decides has power
the person who can say you can't come in
here or as a woman you can't be a priest
has power there
Bob Reata takes a different view she
doesn't speak about power though she
wields it as a manager art historian and
conservator she runs an institution with
a staff of more than 1,000 yatta
considers herself fortunate alongside
her administrative responsibilities
she works in a field that has fascinated
her since she was a child
surrounded by the smells of my mother's
restoration work my sister was also a
conservator of paintings and stone
objects my grandmother was a painter I
watched her making pictures of Rome that
was the environment I grew up in maybe
James and the family do play a role we
see Silla genetic Akuma quilling fruits
of familiar constable Caza growing up in
Rome barber yata was always fascinated
by art she has also learned the skills
of curating an exhibition her entire
life revolves around art and religion
she is currently working on an
exhibition about the history of
Catholicism in Korea the Vatican took an
exhibition to Seoul and this is its
counterpart most of the objects are
being exhibited outside Korea for the
first time Barbara at Earth is
complimenting them with items from the
Vatican's
own collections
Yatta would like to see more
international exhibitions health
especially shows that have relevance to
the Vatican's collections she says she'd
even be prepared to loan out more of the
Vatican's treasures una mostra un precio
de lijn only single operable D de
navarra´ ministry TiVo an exhibition is
more than just a collection of artworks
every item involves work for the
administrators conservators and curators
participar a eleni sativa makandal
initiative it's very important that we
participate in these projects when
they're academically interesting or
promote ecumenism khomeini cocoa mint
antique Ithaca and kaliesha most of all
when a grant realization is the focus as
in the Korea exhibition at Evangelista
Tony Costa Mousa la Carrera I will be
the same South Korea is one of the
Catholic churches success stories this
exhibition documents the beginnings how
in the 17th century diplomats from China
brought the Catholic faith to the Korean
Peninsula this chapter of church history
is being shown at the Vatican for the
first time and the turnout is impressive
Cardinals and senior bishops some of the
Vatican's most powerful men are here
today
barbra yatta is in her element
explaining the structure of the
exhibition Catholicism was introduced
into Korea by laypeople impressed by the
Jesuits in China at first they had to
operate in secret they baptized each
other because there were no priests in
Korea many women were drawn to the new
faith perhaps because it promised
justice and equality the young church
was actively persecuted as recently as
the mid 19th century the exhibition
chronicles this history of suffering and
martyrdom it also documents the strength
and confidence that characterized the
beginnings of the Korean church a Korean
version of the Virgin Mary a clear
indication of how deeply the Koreans
internalized Catholicism
even today many Korean Catholics draw
inspiration and strength from
commemorating this history of courage
and perseverance through the dark days
of persecution the Korean church is very
focused on equality and as always
throughout its history
encouraged women to get involved that
can be observed from the beginning from
the first days of the founding of the
church women have played an important
role
Pope Francis commends women for
witnessing to the faith and he champions
the cause of women
like his predecessors Benedict and John
Paul the second he has a deep devotion
to the Virgin Mary the Catholic icon of
womanhood
but Francis is also a pope who
understands our lives are not simply an
embodiment of ideals he reaches out to
each individual person
this is a pope who encounters men women
and children with the same warmth
compassion and respect although at some
general audiences you might think he was
simply a pop star being mobbed by his
fans
the Pope's deputy spokesperson Paloma
Garcia over here Oh explains the special
report that he seems to have with women
from his caucus II though Pope Francis
grew up surrounded by women what looks
revolutionary in the Vatican is really
quite lenient the Pope always quotes his
grandmother Rosa
he had sisters his mother and close
female friends his right hand in Buenos
Aires was a woman his private secretary
who died a few months ago perhaps it was
this female environment in which Jorge
bergoglio grew up that makes him more
receptive to the role of women in the
church he wants to make sure the church
is accessible to everybody he has
already done a lot to make that happen
in nearly 5 years in office he has
appointed five women as under
secretaries the 3rd highest leadership
level at the Vatican
in Italy mobi Aachen on his last trip to
Colombia
the Pope stated that women should play
important roles in society and in the
church we represent 50 percent of the
population
he says why should this resource be
neglected why shouldn't we view women in
the same way as men and all of us
benefit but gender equality and the role
of women are not at the top of the
agenda everywhere in the church
there is still an immense gap between
the Vatican and secular society when it
comes to promoting women for instance by
means of employment quotas although Pope
Francis never tires of saying that women
must be given more responsibility they
are still woefully underrepresented at
the Vatican not truly then if you
compare him with his predecessors
especially Benedict the sixteenth and
John Paul the second it's clear that he
goes further his predecessors would
never have said something like that they
had a very clear idea that the main duty
of a woman is to serve the family as a
wife and mother and if women go out to
work then only in social professions the
idea that they should do every job that
men do was beyond their comprehension in
that respect
Francis is pretty advanced that is when
this goes from signified Goodwin Zeiler
agrees she has studied the situation of
women at the Vatican for years and has
written books on the role of women in
the church
she believes Pope Francis might soon go
even further in so film is finished I
was personally disappointed that for
instance in the new Vatican Agency for
the lady family in life the Under
Secretary is a priest he could have been
a layperson
maybe the Pope couldn't find a suitable
woman who is prepared to take the job
when a woman has exercised managerial
responsibilities for decades in Catholic
organizations and then has to change to
a number-two position at the Vatican it
might not seem so attractive
then Candice really need to attack atif
are shining Goodwin Tyler is meeting
with her former vatican radio colleague
Romilda far-out oh they are founding
members of donna in vaticano the first
organization representing female staff
at the Vatican it has about a hundred
members who meet once a month to discuss
issues of common concern however these
women don't want to be labeled
feminists networking is the buzzword
their club is a registered Association
which means they have official
recognition and transparent structures
are still afraid to set up an
organization and express themselves
publicly when you talk about a women's
group people immediately think it's
about women being admitted to the
priesthood all those issues that are
still taboo in the Catholic Church but
our society doesn't promote ideas like
that none she saw not for long tagging
with the tea but these women are not
demanding anything they are simply
expressing a desire to make progress
together in the church for crystianna
Florian that's not enough calling the
Bambaataa Congress women working in the
Vatican or in the Catholic Church in
general have to proceed diplomatically
they can't raise the question of power
as such why do only men or ordained men
have the right to make all the decisions
40 years ago even 20 years ago there was
an aggressive generation that fought for
ordination admission to the priesthood
as well as to the diaconate today these
women are either disillusioned and have
left or they've resigned or they've left
the church altogether
although there's strong opposition in
many places to admitting women to the
priesthood a quick survey of tourists in
st. Peter's Square suggests that
European and North American Catholics
are generally open to the idea
traditional it's easier for me to accept
a man as a priest but at the end of the
day I think the situation will change
not soon but sometime maybe the glow G
might benefit from a bit of femininity
the female aspect could open up new
horizons and it's not about positions of
power whether male or female it's about
serving the individual person rank is
not important whether somebody is high
or a lower the real task is to serve
women definitely women are good managers
and I suspect America needs manager
institutions like these as great as they
may be they really should be much more
inclusive and should promote women not
only because they are women but because
they're really good at what they do want
to abolish the patriarchy you should
start with the church that would be a
tremendous signal for believers yes yes
area remain
but is it kill papa if they this Pope
has initiated positive changes it has
modernized the church and we believe he
will complete the task but he needs time
we have full faith in Francis as
Catholics and is Argentinian Romano
teasing
many Catholics believe that Pope Francis
will succeed in reforming the church but
he has stated clearly that he will not
admit women to the priesthood the church
has a long tradition of reserving the
top jobs for men priests bishops and
Cardinals the church's patriarchal
structure is a centuries-old tradition
and tradition is one of the benchmarks
of Catholic theology relatively speaking
Pope Francis is liberal he wants to give
laypeople more responsibility
so it seems quite likely that he will
appoint more women like Barbara yata to
managerial positions so far she has only
met the Pope once he hasn't yet visited
the museums but she's hoping he will she
knows he has a full schedule but then so
does she without efficient planning and
the support of her husband this mother
of three would never be able to manage
the job you mr. Lurgan needs at an
organised my life well of course it's
more difficult with the children but we
divided up the household chores
that wasn't very common 30 years ago do
not that that kid not let up at school I
was lucky
Anthony FAC Wando I was able to combine
family and work I think I've managed my
children are wonderful but in the end
must be grateful give cerro de la vita
punto you know the vCenter ingress
arrival okay
Barbara otters simple positive way of
accepting things stems from her faith if
she didn't believe she wouldn't be able
to work at the Vatican art and religion
are inseparable here and as with the
Korean exhibition the focus is often the
universal Church
luckily three tables about about a [ __ ]
territory they move a column
no no my pencil if I can but I never
intended to have a career at the Vatican
even the idea of it is strange I just
tried to do my work as well as I could
all of the Directorate was a Vatican II
because it's my role as director of the
Vatican Museums puts a lot of
responsibility on my shoulders but it's
also a privilege I'm very conscious of
the fact that I work for the Holy Father
and for the conservation of this
tremendous world heritage Bashar Momin
tener la cuesta grande patrimonio que
empezar monitor Luminita in Bob regattas
first year as director of the Vatican
Museums she has made some changes and
initiated some projects but above all
she is the custodian of collections
representing 2,000 years of Christianity
and thousands of years of world culture
you